A war has been raging
for billions of years,
cunning trillions every single
day. Well, we don't even notice.
The war is fought by the single
deadliest entity on our Panisse.
The bacteria phage or Phage for short.
A phage is a virus not quite alive,
not quite dead.
Also,
they look as if someone made them up.
The head is an icosahedron assault
of dice with 20 faces and 30 ages.
It contains the genetic material of the
virus and often sits on a long tail that
has leg like fibers.
There are more phages on earth
than every other organism combined,
including bacteria,
and they are probably everywhere.
Living things exist.
Billions are on your hands and your
intestines and your eyelids right now,
which might make you nervous it since
features are responsible for the majority
of deaths on earth,
but you're lucky.
While they do commit
genocide for breakfast,
they only kill bacteria up to 40% of
all bacteria in the oceans are killed by
them every single day.
But features also have major
floors like any other virus.
Pleasers need a host to
survive and reproduce.
They're not much more than genetic
material in a hole and they specialize.
Usually a phage has chosen one specific
bacteria and maybe some of it's very
close relatives.
These are its prey.
Imagine a Phage eyes like a cruise missile
that only hunts and kills members of
one very unlucky family.
When a phage finds its victim,
it connects it's towel fibers with
receptors and uses a sort of syringe to
puncture the surface in a weird motion.
The phages squeezes it's tail and
injects its genetic information.
Within minutes the bacteria is taken over.
It's now forced to manufacture
all the parts of new phages.
They only stop when the bacteria
is filled up with brand new phages.
In the final step,
they produce an ender license,
a powerful enzyme that punches
a hole in the bacteria.
The pressure is so high that
the bacteria sort of calm,
it's out all of its insights and dies.
New Features are released
and begin the cycle anew.
In the last few years,
bacteria phages have enjoyed the intention
of the second Deb DSP beings on earth.
Schumann's recently we've started looking
into injecting millions of them into
our bodies because we're sort of
getting desperate. We screwed up
in the past. A single cart or set
from the wrong puddle could kill you.
Bacteria were our phages tiny
monsters that hunted us mercilessly.
But about 100 years ago,
we found a solution in nature by accident,
we found funky that produced a compound
that kills bacteria, antibiotics.
Suddenly we had a powerful super weapon.
Antibiotics was so effective that we
stopped thinking of bacteria as monsters.
Only the old and the weakest
among us were killed by them.
We used antibiotics more and more
for less and less serious causes.
We lost respect for the
monsters and the weapon,
but bacteria are living things that evolve
and one by one they started to become
immune against our ovens.
This continued until we had
created what are called super bugs,
bacteria,
immune to almost everything we have.
This immunity is spreading
across the world as we speak.
By 2050 superbugs could kill
more humans a year than cancer.
The days when a cart or bladder infection
or a cough could kill you or your
loved ones are coming back in the u s
alone more than 23,000 people die from
resistant bacteria each year,
but it turns out that phages our tiny
killer virus robots could save us.
We could inject them into our bodies
to help cure infections. Hold on.
How could injecting millions of viruses
into an infection be a good idea?
Phages are very,
very specialized killers of bacteria,
so specialized in face that humans
are completely immune to them.
We are two different,
we encounter billions of phages
every day and we just pull nightly,
ignore each other.
Antibiotics are like a carpet bombing,
killing everything.
Even the good bacteria in our
intestines that we don't want to harm.
Phages are like guided missiles that only
attack what they're supposed to wait a
minute is if we use phages to kill
bacteria when bacteria develop ways of
defending themselves. Well,
it's more complex than that.
Phages evolve too.
There has been an arms race between Batman
bacteria for billions of years and so
far they're doing great.
This makes phages smart weapons that are
constantly getting better at killing,
but even if bacteria were to become
immune against how phage we still might be
able to win.
It turns out that in order to become
resistance to even just a few species of
phages bacteria have to give up
their resistance to antibiotics,
we might be able to
trap them in a catch 22
this has already been successfully tested
with a patient who had no other hope
left the bacteria pseudomonas Aeruginosa,
one of the most feared bacteria
infected the man's chest cavity.
They are naturally resistant to most
antibiotics and can even survive an
alcoholic hand gel.
After years of suffering,
a few thousand features were directly
inserted into his chest cavity.
Together with antibiotics, the bacteria
were immune to. After a few weeks,
the infections had completely disappeared.
Unfortunately,
this treatment is still experimental and
Pharma companies are still reluctant to
invest the necessary billions
in a treatment that has
no official approval yet,
but things are finally changing.
In 2016 the largest phage clinical trial
to date began and phages are getting
more and more attention and we better
get used to it because the era in which
antibiotics have been our super
weapon is drawing to a close.
It might be a weird concept,
but injecting the deadliest
being on planet earth
directly into our bodies could
save millions of lives.
This video was made possible by a
grant from the bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation. If you'd like to
support cards cause our do,
you can do so on patrion.com/ [inaudible]
and get fancy things in return.